I want to play this recording for you of
um
president Trump that just came out and
I'm sure you've seen it and there's a
response from the president from the
president as well if you want to play
this this is what everybody's CNN
everyone's playing saying this is it
it's the end of it after this he
shouldn't be qualified to run if you
want to go ahead and play this and then
we'll we'll show his response sick
people but that was your cue you know
against you well it started right what
Millie's talking about oh you were going
to try to do a kick now they were trying
to do that before you even were sworn in
that's right trying to overthrow your
life well with Millie uh let me see that
I'll show you an example he said that I
wanted to attack Iran
isn't it amazing I have a big pile of
papers this thing just came off look
this was him
they presented me this is off the Record
but they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
we looked at some this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him all sorts
of stuff
keep playing it keep playing wait a
minute
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly confidential
there's a secret information look at
this you attack and Hillary would print
that out all the time
I should send it to Anthony Weiner
um by the way is that incredible yeah I
was just saying because we were talking
about it and you know he said he wanted
to attack Iran and what he's in the face
this was done by the military given to
me
can you pause this Rob so who's
recording this uh according to CNN the
audio recording comes from a July 2021
interview Trump gave at his bed Minister
Resort for people working uh on a memoir
for Mark Meadows Trump's former Chief of
Staff okay so go to his who's that lady
who is that lady is that one of his
staffers uh it says here in the article
that the people present a writer
publisher and two of Trump's staff
members two of trump staff members okay
so now go to Trump's response on what he
says about this on Truth social uh uh uh
you know so the deranged specials
process special prosecutor Jack's been
working in conjunction with the doj and
FBI illegally leaked and spunny tape and
transcript of me which is actually an
exoneration rather than what they would
have you believe the discontinuing Witch
Hunt is another election interfering
scam they are cheaters and thugs so when
you see this recording and you see
you know him talking about Millie and
and you know where he's at and Hillary
and all this other stuff how do you
process this when you see this recording
that uh the media is using to make sure
he can no longer compete for 2024.
well the first thing that I I think uh
is that
president Trump is not unlike most of
his predecessors in that many of the
papers that they took with them when
they left office were not necessarily
carefully uh vetted registered
Declassified whatever
uh I I think we've over the years become
very relaxed in that area secondly I
think we classify too much
that's certainly true
and it's unfortunate that that they're
trying very very hard to pin pin some
sort of criminal action on him which is
of course absurd now
his point is effectively true
the million others came across along
with Bolton and as I recollect uh the
the former
Secretary of State who was was Pompeo
who said he wanted to run for president
bowed out
they were all advocates for war with
Iran and you have to look at at least
with Bolton and Pompeo who their quote
unquote donors are where their money
comes from
they wanted war with Iran Millie I'm not
sure he was a strong advocate for it I
have no idea but he certainly wasn't
going to stand in the way we know that
Mackenzie who is down in U.S Central
Command he
apparently his fingerprints are all over
this Global Hawk on unmanned aerial
vehicle that was shot down it was it was
plotted to follow the edge of the air
defense identification Zone which under
international law says that any military
aircraft that violates that zone is
liable to be shot down unless it
identifies itself explains its position
and so forth of course we didn't do that
so in a court of law the Iranians of
international law would have won the
case
at the time no one could say what
happens if we go to war with Iran the
idea was we got to go to war with Iran
it was similar to the well wolfowitz
Rumsfeld Shaney cabal that took us into
Iraq the the purpose is to get us into
Iraq then we'll figure it out very
similar to things that were said in 1965
and 66 about Vietnam well what are we
going to do there how well we've got to
get in there let's get in there we'll
sort through that we'll quote unquote
muddle through you never muddle through
you have to know what the purpose is you
have to know how you're going to achieve
that purpose and then you have to have a
vision for what you want it to look like
at the end we call that purpose method
end state
Donald Trump
as president of the United States
prevented war with Iran because he asked
first of all
what happens after we launch all of
these strikes
what happens now he said at the time I
was concerned about the loss of human
life in Iran which is legitimate
especially since we did not lose any
human life what we did is we lost an
unmanned aerial vehicle which he did not
think Rose to the threshold that
justified war with Iran and of course he
was right
but it was also a question of okay we
launched all these strikes then what
and you have a lot of people in
Washington that just want to start
something and then convince themselves
they can drag Us in and that somehow or
another the military will make it work
that happened to us in Vietnam it
happened to us in Iraq it happened to us
in Afghanistan it happened to us in
Libya it's happening right now in an
attempt to bring us into some sort of
confrontation with the Russians over
Ukraine
and there are no Syria there's no
serious thinking about what are the
implications what Iran is an enormous
country it's almost the size of Western
Europe it has a large population
let's assume that you can destroy Iran
all right let's just assume you can
destroy it with enough weapons they
can't stand up to us with their air
defense networks or anything else so
let's assume you're right we destroy
them what do these people do well they
leave
they begin to pour into surrounding
countries because there's nothing for
them to eat there's no water to drink
if you destroy Iran what's the impact
strategically on the region is there
anybody there who benefits from it well
a lot of people seem to think the Turks
would Mr erdogan would then emerge as
the preeminent power in the region
because Iran's really his principle
arrived yeah so why would you do that
does that make sense
doesn't make a lot of sense these are
the discussions the British and American
General staffs behind the scenes had
during World War II you want us to
destroy Germany then what
who supplants Germany the Soviet Union
is that our goal do you understand what
I'm saying I'm following Trump did a
good thing he said no I'm not going to
do this I'm not going to support it
and of course you know donors everywhere
were very unhappy because they donated
prolifically to that Administration in
the hopes of bringing on a war with Iran
remember I think it was potorets who
said every morning I get up and pray
that we go to war with Iran and he was
advising John McCain and McCain was an
advocate for going to war with Iran
McCain was in Kiev saying we'll we'll
fight the Russians we'll stand by you
this is before he passed away
I mean this is lunacy
what is happening who is in charge the
American people don't know what war
means I've seen a country devastated by
war I've seen more than one they don't
understand that we are no longer in a
position of Splendid isolation where we
can destroy other people's homes without
risking the same here when you start
dealing with the Russians and the
Chinese all sorts of potentially bad
things can happen if you think Mexico is
our friend I have news for you the
Mexicans have always sided with whomever
was against the United States so is
Venezuela and so is Cuba
now you really want to go to war with
these people and then have a second
front in the Caribbean in Latin America
do you want to be dragged into that no
one is thinking there is no strategic
thought and no one is thinking about the
American people what's in the interest
of the American people you know what's
in the interest of the American people
build prosperity
recover this economy repatriate jobs get
control of the Border stop the influx of
Labor that we can't employ and if we
believe the AI Fanatics who are telling
us that by what 19 what is it 1940 or
what is it 2040 or something
80 percent of all the current
low-skilled jobs will be replaced by AI
what are we bringing most of these
people in to do it's insane doesn't make
any sense so who's thinking about the
United States American society
nobody do you think this can be used to
eliminate him as a as a candidate or it
still doesn't do anything like they're
they're using everything possible to
eliminate him do you think you know
yesterday I tweeted something Rob if he
can go to Twitter this is just something
I I tweeted yesterday and it got some
people that were uh uh some were upset
some were curious and some were like you
know why the hell would you even put
this out there so go in and zoom in
right there that one right there if we
can make it bigger okay 2024 strategy to
have Newsome replace Biden okay step
number one have Newsom go around
defending Biden selling Biden's record
shows loyalty step number two have him
constantly attack DeSantis Dems are
convinced Trump will be forced to drop
out step number three if Biden doesn't
step down have mainstream media attack
him it's already happened in ABC CBS NBC
all one after I'm starting this week
step number four Once Jill Jill Biden
notices these endless attacks have a
private meeting with Biden sharing
strategy to save face if he steps down
step number one multiple documentaries
shown him as a modern day FDR number two
massive Simon and Schuster book deal
three defend his legacy and be pardoned
by Newsom if hits the fan next one
choose one a few options to step down
number one due to help number two Jill
and I prayed about it and decided it's
time for us to go spend time with our
grandkids number three we fix everything
Trump broke and now it's time for
someone else to do it number four edify
Newsome as being loyal to Biden unlike
the centers not being loyal to Trump so
then in order to prevent Kamala from
backstab and let her become the first
female president for Split Second
when Biden steps down Hillary will lose
her mind but what's new and number seven
divide DeSantis and Trump Camp to make
sure Mega doesn't vote for DeSantis step
number eight that says Newsom becomes 47
but I should have said 48 and last but
not least it's very likely none of the
above will happen which is why it's
called a prediction but only the
paranoids survive so do you think like
you know do you think Trump's going to
be there next year as a republican
candidate
well first of all only the paranoid
survive is one of the best books I've
ever read Andy Grove he recommended it
to me and if you want to understand
what's wrong with the military
establishment all you have to do is read
what he describes in there with IBM and
all these other major corporations it's
a brilliant book I I try to get
everybody to read it
now secondly first of all I think it's
brilliant
and I think that if we were living in a
linear World in other words we're one
one event follows the next logically
you're absolutely right I don't think
we'll ever get to the 2024 election
I think things are going to implode in
Washington before then
I think our economic Financial condition
is fragile it's going to come home to
roost in ugly ways now I will tell you I
don't know exactly how it will happen I
think we're going to end up in a
situation where we find out the banks
are closed for two or three weeks and
nobody can get into them you think so I
think we're going to run into something
like that yeah I also think that the
levels of violence and criminality in
our cities is so high
that it's going to spill over into other
places in society people that normally
think they can live remote from the
problem are now beginning to be touched
by the problem
then I look at this thing in Ukraine I
think Ukraine is going to lose
catastrophically it's going to be a
complete collapse and that too is going
to have an effect here at home because
people are going to say well wait a
minute everybody told us Ukraine was
winning everybody told us X Y and Z I
mean sort of the the Russian hoax on
steroids
all of those things are going to come
together or converge in some way that's
going to prevent us from reaching you
know the status quo oh another election
oh another set of campaigns and so forth
so what you're saying to me is eminently
plausible because I don't think Biden
will make it through the year I think
it'll be gone and I think everybody
knows that this person Kamala Harris
lacks the ability under any
circumstances to be president of the
United States when you say gone I mean
passing away because of this age or
merely being incapable and finally being
what is that what do they call it 25th
amendment whatever it is shuffled off
the stage I think I still say face
though they'll do it in a way to say
exactly
right yeah I think what Patrick wrote is
accurate something like that will happen
and then the the search begins and
Newsome is The Logical candidate for
them he's presiding over California
which is their poster child for the
future of America if you want to know
what the Democrats want America to
become Look at California how deeply and
dead is California what's the state of
affairs in that in that country of its
own it's catastrophe everyone who can
leave that has any Talent ability or
understanding is leaving
businesses are leaving no one wants to
be there so what are you going to end up
with a very small minority of very
wealthy people and millions of poor
people
most of whom don't even don't even
consider themselves to be Americans so
that's that's the Dream World for the
left California yeah I don't think we'll
tolerate that
so I don't think it'll ever get that far
on the national level no I could be
wrong
but I don't think we're that complacent
I also know that you get revolutionary
change when people can't eat
when the supply chains break down and
you can't deliver food when they can't
afford to buy the food when they can't
afford to buy the gasoline these things
are the catalysts for real change and
everyone's betting that the left in
charge in Washington can keep all of
this going without any Interruption
maybe they're right I don't think so
yeah I think that the Gloom in you know
what is it the the bloom and doom gloom
and doom of the chances of that for me
it's less than five percent again my
opinion you you got you we well see I
don't see that as gloom and doom I see
that as our savior
fine I by the way but here's the
challenge I I actually agree with the
fact that if they would have allowed
Powell to do his job as the Fed chair to
increase interest rates and inflate it
to the rate to decrease inflation
we would have gone through a transition
phase where people would have realized
hey man this whole fake success we had
the last 120 829 month economic
expansion is done but we realized
everybody including us that we thought
Jerome Powell was one of the most
powerful men in America or the world
he's not congresses Congress came out
and said no here's Prince of money sent
into the economy it's going to be fine
don't worry about it guys we'll show
more fake success to the economy holy
you know these stocks are back up
these guys are doing back again based on
the seven stocks that's coming back up
you know what
you know it's not going to happen so
he's preventing that it's like a delay
in the time bomb we're eventually going
to go through it could be 5 10 15.
someone has to eventually go through
with the right policies but whoever does
they're not going to get reelected so
you almost have to have more fake
success to get reelected it's terrible
for America it's not a good thing but
it's the structure that we've created
happy Fourth of July too we have a
special event that's coming up with Tom
Brady Mike Tyson and we'll get there in
Miami Vault conference it'll be August
30th to September 2nd this weekend for
Fourth of July we're running a special
buy one get one free bring your spouse
bring your business partner bring your
running mate if you haven't yet
registered click on the link below or
above get registered looking forward to
spending three days with you in Miami
thank you
[Music]